kylie jenner is showing off her baby
bump and we love to see it i love it
while the makeup mogul kept her first
pregnancy with daughter stormi webster
under wraps she's seemingly cool with
burying it all with baby number two and
let's just say the kylie cosmetics
founder is definitely working a sexy
mirror selfie while showing off her best
accessory it's fun kylie shared this pic
to instagram on tuesday wearing an
oversized gray trench coat with a crop
top that perfectly frames her growing
baby bump the caption i'm ready for fall
and baby number two is almost ready to
pop as the reality star shared this pic
writing belly's getting big with two
white heart emojis this isn't the first
time kylie has shown off her bump style
earlier this month during new york
fashion week the soon to be mom of two
wore a similar fit and later donned a
sheer lace bodysuit for a night out on
the town but we gotta say this all white
leather fit has to be one of her most
show-stopping looks ever are you ready
to go to mommy's doctor yeah
honestly you're days away
a couple of days away
[Music]
kylie confirmed reports she was
expecting baby number two with a special
video diary and a source recently told
dt that she wanted to share the happy
news on her own terms
[Music]
the source added that kylie's boyfriend
travis scott has been doting on the
reality star and hardly leaves her side
quote their relationship is in a
beautiful space and they are more in
love than ever and so incredibly excited
about the future
[Music]
but the thing they're most excited about
giving their three-year-old daughter
stormi a sibley
[Music]
as for kylie's famous fam the source
says they are the biggest supporters
quote her family is so excited
especially because they all love travis
they're also offering to help wherever
and whenever especially mom kris jenner
and according to our source kylie knows
her hands are going to be even fuller
when baby number two arrives so she is
welcoming any advice especially from her
mom and sisters kim and kourtney
kardashian the family grows and it's
getting bigger all the time and yeah
it's really fun to see the babies have
babies kim recently talked to ellen
degeneres about the newest addition to
the family and hilariously joked there
might be more coming you're not going to
have another baby maybe another sister i
have other sisters yeah and a brother
yeah maybe someone should yeah but
you're done right you're you're yeah yes
yeah yes i think so
i mean i think yeah i'm done yeah yeah
yeah i have a lot i have a lot of kids
i'm done yeah
i'm just i'm telling you you're done
i'm going to make the decision for you